part of the issue with things like this
is people defining value for people that
aren't them
I am Nicolas be with reason TV and today
we're talking with Courtney baliker
she's the director of a forthcoming
movie called little pink house which is
about the kylo eminent domain decision
from a few years back Courtney thanks
for talking to us thanks for having me
recap the story of Suzette kylo and her
little pink calves Suzette kylo was a
blue-collar working-class woman studying
to be a nurse in 1999 found a house that
was broken down she was just coming out
of a marriage all five boys had grown
gone out of the house and she really
just wanted a peaceful quiet life and
she found this dilapidated home built it
back up with her bare hands and the
thing that was remarkable about it had a
beautiful view of the Thames River in
New London Connecticut and so she built
it up put furniture in it and painted it
pink meanwhile Pfizer pharmaceutical was
on the other side of the Thames River
and they had just invented a drug called
viagra and they were looking to expand
their facility and the city wanted to
make sure that they would be able to do
that into New London but they needed
space to build a campus hotel things for
Pfizer pharmaceutical so the governor of
Connecticut at the time Governor John G
Rowland made a very friendly environment
in New London so that Pfizer would be
able to acquire the land and use it for
their space unfortunately Sue's Aquila's
property was on one of the parcels of
that land and they used they meaning the
city used eminent domain to make sure
that she and her neighbors would be gone
so they kind of like they declare the
whole area blighted or whatever and then
they say we're taking it through the
power of eminent domain yeah and then
they just immediately were turning it
over to a private developer it was it
was a little bit of a process but the
word blight was used because in order to
use eminent domain you have to show well
this area needs to be redeveloped maybe
it's dangerous it was not blight these
were older Victorian homes some of the
people that lived in these homes were
born in them most of the neighborhood
were elderly people
and the city basically offered them
money is that that's always how it
starts but of course it they low ball
and they low ball but the real issue is
you can't define someone's value you
can't I can't go up to you and say look
I know what the market value of your
house is I'll give that to you well that
that value could be way more than money
maybe your grandfather built that house
maybe this is your dream house that
you've always wanted what's the price
tag on that so part of the issue with
things like this is people defining
value for people that aren't them now
the the case ended up going to the
Supreme Court
yes and Susette Kelo did not win that
case she didn't she said kilo fought all
the way and she did not want to be the
face of eminent domain in this country
she wanted a quiet peaceful existence
but she knew that what was happening was
wrong and so she stood up and it went to
the state Supreme Court first and she
actually did win on that but they split
the baby as they said some of her
neighbors would have to leave while she
and a few others could stay and so she
and a few others said no either we all
stay or we all go and then when they
revisited that decision they lost and
then it went up to the United States
Supreme Court where she lost again so
this is a classic David and Goliath
story or I don't know what the female
version of David is but it's Dolores
versus Goliath and what's interesting in
Hollywood is that a lot of the times
it's you know it's it's an agent of the
government you know a social worker or a
teacher or a lawyer going against an
evil corporation so this kind of flips
that a little bit doesn't it does flip
it a little bit the agent in this case
was the New London Development Committee
and they were basically an organization
that was put in place by the government
really to bring in a corporation like
Pfizer so that they could redevelop it
it is a David and Goliath story because
all of the powerful people all the
people with money and all of the people
with connections and pull were in the
driver's seat and Suzette kilo didn't
have
Pyles money wasn't lawyered up in the
beginning of this process and so it
really was a grassroots David and
Goliath story when you look at Suzette
kilo and what she did essentially what
happened is eminent domain was not used
in its proper way eminent domain is
typically used to expand roads build
hospitals build schools it's not used so
that I can take from one private
individual and give it to another
private individual which is essentially
what happened but there are certain
Supreme Court justices who said yes but
it was for the betterment of the
community because it would create more
tax revenue and and that also it went
across ideological lines there were some
conservatives and liberals in making the
decision that yet the government can
take whatever property they want as long
as it's you know good for society or
something when the decision came out in
2005 it was a very very close decision
it was a four or five decision and it
was remarkable how it United the country
no matter what your politics were that
90% of Americans agreed that it was a
bad decision I mean in a weird way I
mean they won she lost in the Supreme
Court of the United States but then it
touched off this kind of widespread
rebellion against them and it domain
abuse yeah when I talked to some people
about is that such a bummer ending she
didn't win well that's true but
unfortunately I think very tragic things
have to happen sometimes before people
will pay attention and I think that the
silver lining behind this very bad
decision this very awful thing that she
went through really ten-year ordeal that
she and her neighbors went through
wondering if they were going to be
homeless being asked to pay rent on
their own property at one point this was
not a quick thing but the silver lining
is that it was such an outrageous
decision that everyone was talking about
it major media outlets were covering it
and most people agree that it was a very
bad thing and I don't think people would
be talking about eminent domain abuse
had she won and as an epilogue about 45
states curbed their eminent domain laws
so that this type of thing couldn't
happen again
and tell us what ended up being built on
the land there are some feral cats that
are building little I guess
dirt beds and rats and weeds so it's it
really turned out to be a great project
Pfizer ended up not building nothing was
built in fact 10 years have gone by has
gone by now and there have been ideas
that percolate one of the funniest
things I read last year was that
somebody had the idea of you know what
we should build and this parcel of land
we should maybe build like a parking lot
with like little houses next to it that
people could and the writer said you
mean like the one that you tore down the
little pink house you start filming in
the fall yes so we have we are fully
funded we are greenlit film our
production schedule is to shoot in
September and we're in the casting
process now and we are just so excited
to get this movie made and out into the
world we want to entertain people we
want to tell us through that story but
we also want to tell people what
happened eminent domain abuse is still a
problem there are little pink houses all
across the country and so there's a
social action campaign behind the film -
and we really want to put an end to what
happened to Suzette well thank you so
much we'll look forward when it comes
out
Courtney baliker the movie is little
pink house it's about Suzette kilo
fighting the government and helping to
curb eminent domain abuse Courtney
thanks for talking to thank you for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie